how are you
i'm good how you doing i am well i
appreciate you talking to me
about this i thought it was just so
beautifully done and this is a couple
that
feels easy to feel for and root for so
when you first read this script and were
introduced to these characters and their
story
what were the emotions that you went
through with them what what
most touches you about their story i
mean if i'm completely honest i think
when you're looking at material and
thinking about whether to
get involved in a project you haven't
really quite has
gotten as far as to sort of dig into the
emotions and
the story it's more i guess a bit more
calculated than that you're reading the
material for whether it's something that
you like whether you like the dialogue
whether it's a sort of
subject matter that you kind of have a
response to or
an affinity with um
so again that's the first first sort of
thing that happens
i also listened to or read the article
listen to
um the podcast which is a reading of the
article as well
and got the kind of vibe of that
um the new york new york times article
itself
um so that's where i started and and i
just yeah i was interested in
i guess because it's a mixture of
obviously we're doing a dramatization
but it's
um it's uh non-fiction
in its um when it was published and so
it's you know rea
someone this couple's real life so
that's inherently uh uh
drew me into it um
and yes and then it will really it was
later on
once we started making it that was how
to sort of engage in
yeah what the what the journey of this
couple is you know obviously um
uh uh sort of the more complicated
aspect of that being
her diagnosis and you know what
i had a sort of how to do justice to
that
um yeah because so much of this
is you and sophie what did you most
enjoy about working with her
as a scene partner what do you think she
brought to
all of this as an actor herself
really um yeah one of the best actors
i've worked with
she is really authentic very
honest about stuff um and really
kind of insists that it kind of happens
in front of the camera
and can't fake it um
which is a really galvanizing energizing
thing to be around
it's exciting um we also
yeah we had a similar way of working we
were both interested in digging into the
scripts
with kieran and john in the sort of week
or two leading up to it
um talking about possible changes or you
know
or whether there was stuff that we could
cut and and they were
open to that too and so that side of it
i i definitely
find that uh helpful as a sort of way
into this
you know into material where there's a
bit of a there can be some push and pull
some some conversation around
um the actual material itself um
yeah so it was a you never quite know
when you head into these things but
it was a pretty happy collaboration i
think everyone
all of us were kind of pulling in the
same direction we were interested in
making
the same kind of show and totally
interested in
um the same things i think
i'm a fan of john carney's work i loved
sing street and once
how familiar were you with his work what
do you think it is that makes his work
special
um well once was certainly a a film that
i had really admired
um i mean having worked with him now um
i was really struck by
there's a kind of freewheeling quality
to how he shoots
so he really does sort of um he doesn't
it's not
too controlling he really
um keeps it to a minimum in terms of
your sense of being filmed it's
quite light touch and
um and he didn't do huge amounts of
takes so he
seemed to really have confidence in us
as performers
and yeah so he would really let things
play not intervene
too much um and i think
i think that's partly why his work has
quite a fresh um authentic
almost improvisatory quality um
he yeah that sort of light touch sort of
non-invasive
and that particularly paid off you know
obviously we were working with
two little girls playing our kids and um
yeah he was very good at also keeping
the kind of
techniques of what we were doing uh in
the background so that they could
be kind of quite relaxed and quite free
having done shows like game of thrones
and outlander and the crown you've been
on some sets of the largest scale
what most stands out to you about being
a part
of productions of that size and scale
especially when compared to something so
much smaller and more intimate
like modern love yeah that's partly why
i wanted to go and do modern love
because i've
fancied a change of pace and this felt
you know obviously it's modern story
a very different kind of show than
something like the crown
less less overtly dramatic
um so yeah
um i like them both but um
it was very nice to go and do something
a little more intimate a little smaller
um where you know the smaller team
um quicker kind of conversation around
it
what do you remember about your
experience on
rome which was sort of one of the
earlier big large-scale
tv productions before it was as much of
a thing as it is now
yeah um yes i mean one of the sort of
early trailblazers of you know a lot of
the shows that came after
um very happy memories i was pretty
young it was my first
big american tv production that i'd done
um yeah and i remember you know um
i remember again going and talking to
the showrunners about
the script on that one too and being
sufficiently uh young and naive uh you
know
not to know any better and no one told
me to bugger off so
um yeah so they were very kind then and
i've
um yeah i've also continued to be really
i mean it's amazing how many people
continue to
reference that show as both an important
show but also maybe a
a an influential show um for some of the
stuff that came after
you're also someone who's had an
extensive career
on the stage or an experienced stage
actor
what do you think that how has that
influenced and affected your work as an
actor in front of the camera do you feel
like that's had an effect
on how you perform on camera undoubtedly
i like
it's not it's not clear-cut i think it's
um
all these things contribute but yeah
it's definitely where
fundamentally i learned to act it's
where a lot of my early career was it's
where i made a lot of my mistakes cut my
teeth
you know got it wrong then learned to
get it right and
um so in that sense it's
hugely formative and and also continue
to be because i mean one of the
interesting things about this is you get
a very very direct feedback
unlike screen um where it takes months
for it to sort of actually hit an
audience or
for you to see it in a in a live
theater it's very clear you know what
people's response are
and so there's there's an immediacy to
that
which means that you grow pretty quickly
through doing that
there's sort of no hiding place and
that's really
you know i think
really good for actors to do it keeps
you like fit i think
and so that's definitely my feeling
about it and um
and so that's why you know i continue to
go back
and continue to do it yeah it's
definitely the thing that seems
exciting and terrifying in equal measure
so
you that can be terrifying moments yeah
well thank you so much for talking to me
good to talk to you too take care